[Música]
el mar
[Aplausos]
hola cómo están
como mi charla se titula les vengo a
hablar un poco de innovación social y su
relación con la ingeniería
ese que ven ahí soy yo cuando chico y
eso es parte de mi familia
cuando era chico era super curioso y
super inquieto y eso generó que desde el
lobo ocasional me inclinara por
distintas profesiones de distintas
disciplinas que me van interesando a lo
largo de mi vida primero
quiere ser arquitecto me encantaban las
ciudades pensaba cómo se podía construir
grandes edificios o inimaginables casas
pero también me gustaba mucho el fútbol
desde chico me gustó aunque no era muy
buena para la pelota entonces dije bueno
si no puedo hacer jugar de fútbol voy a
ser periodista pero específicamente
relator de partidos de fútbol y jugaba a
relatar los distintos partidos que iba
que iba viendo
pero parece que tampoco le tiraba mucho
y me empezaron a interesar otras cosas
me interesó la historia me interesó la
literatura y fui pasando por distintas
ideas pero como ocurre en nuestras veces
en esa etapa vertiginosa
la adolescencia especialmente cuando uno
llega a la educación media uno más que
ir tomando las decisiones por uno mismo
se va dejando llevar por lo que la
corriente las opiniones o las fuerzas
externas te van dirigiendo
de hecho la primera decisión que tuve
que tomar y que de repente me enfrenté a
ella fue elegir en algo que nunca antes
me haya cuestionado
me dio al curso humanista o mío el curso
científico una dicotomía que me parecía
desde ya muy extraña
como le pegaba un poquito en las
matemáticas y la física bueno las
fuerzas me empujaron hacia el lado
científico y bueno hay que irse al curso
científico
ahí es donde empezamos a trabajar en
matemáticas en física en química
tanto a mí como a un grupo de compañeros
nuestros profesores con cariño nos
decían ingenieros tú estás aparece una
profesión nueva aparece algo en que no
haya considerado hasta ese momento
parece que por el hecho de pegarle un
poco a la física de pegarle un poco a la
química y a las matemáticas había que
estudiar esta carrera que bien poco
entendía lo que hacía pero que parece
que era lo que había que hacer
así que viene la pregunta o la siguiente
pregunta ya saliendo del colegio qué
especialidad me iba a inclinar y aquí a
universidad de hoy obviamente las
fuerzas externas ejerciendo su juego
en ese momento la más popular en
ingeniería seguir industrial no tenía
idea lo que hacía
si me preguntaba en ese momento en que
se diferenciada con las otras
no lo habría sabido explicar
pero bueno era lo que era top en ese
momento y dije
allá vamos además decían que te
asegurado un buen pasar
así que vayan fuimos
la universidad fue un poquito más fácil
porque
unirse a ingenieros y la verdad que
quién no querría estudiar en ese
castillo y recorrer las calles de esa
ciudad del acierto y harry potter y
jaguares historia no existirán
después entramos a la universidad y con
mis compañeros empezamos a ir en las
aulas a encontrarnos con estos
profesores que nos hablaban de
electrónica de mecánica de química de
informática un sinfín de herramientas
nos prometieron que nos iban a servir
para algo y se empezó a normalizar entre
nosotros que los que estudiábamos
ingeniería especialmente ingeniería sin
industria nos estábamos preparando para
ser gerentes
gerentes de grandes empresas esa era la
medida del éxito para nosotros
de emprendimiento en esa época ni se
hablaba
ya los bichos raros eran los que querían
dedicarse a otro tipo de cosas
por ejemplo a la academia y ahí fue
precisamente donde yo encontré un camino
ante preguntas que me empezando en
términos para que me iba a servir todo
esto para que me va a servir tanta
matemática tanta física tanta química
que era lo que yo iba realmente a
contribuir con ello especialmente
cuestionándome todos los otros intereses
que en ese momento tenía
con ella
dicotomía que me hayan forzado a elegir
la ciencia y descartar lo humanista
y encontré para suerte la respuesta en
la academia médica y así en las
conversaciones en la lectura en el aula
con mis mismos estudiantes pues de
alguna manera sentirme más realizable y
dios de forma integral porque después
todo esto porque como podrán ver el
derrotero para mí como seguramente
muchos de nosotros nos ha pasado fue
bastante azaroso tuve suerte terminé
trabajando en algo que me encanta pero
cuando yo lo miro un poco a distancia se
me generan diversas inquietudes
la figura del ingeniero
hay en montones de preguntas que
nosotros buscamos lo que hace un
ingeniero en internet no aparecían en la
conversación hace 15 o 20 años cuando yo
estudié
los ingenieros cuando nosotros
proyectamos en nuestro imaginario son
cuadrados o cúbicos como decimos en la
santamaría
poco nos preocupábamos un poco nos
inquieta vamos por la creatividad la
innovación el emprendimiento y la
resolución de problemas más allá de lo
que pasaba dentro de la fábrica o dentro
de la empresa
y menos nos preguntábamos para qué oa
quién le iba a servir eso la tecnología
y la ingeniería se transformaban más en
un fin que en un medio para algo más
los imaginarios son fundamentales son
importantes para la construcción de las
ideas para inspirar e incluso para
marcar el deber ser
por ejemplo eso también ocurre en las
profesiones la cultura popular
contribuye mucho a eso pensemos en la
serie de las películas siguieras
pregunta especialmente a los que no se
dedican a profesiones vinculadas con la
medicina qué es lo que hace un médico o
cómo es el día a día de un médico seguro
muchos de ustedes se están imaginando al
doctor house con sus diagnósticos muy
acertados o al trabajo en equipo de guía
si les pregunto lo que hace un abogado o
lo que hace un publicista seguramente
más de alguno está pensando
en suites o en don draper the mad men
con su elegancia toda pulcra y suelo
puedo o sea al momento de defender un
caso o vender un producto una marca esta
es fácil
un arqueólogo
ya sabes cierto todos inmediatamente
estamos pensando las aventuras de
indiana jones
por supuesto estos son todos personajes
pero seguramente a todas estas
profesiones más de algún momento les ha
tocado acercarse a lo que estos
personajes viven pero más allá de eso en
el día a día probablemente son mucho más
rutinarias son mucho más tranquilas
de lo que estos personajes viven pero
son fundamentales la personaje de la
construcción de un imaginario para
establecer los objetivos y la misión de
cada una de estas profesiones
cuando yo les digo ahora pensemos en
ingenieros
la mente
probablemente
estos personajes
sheldon y jaguar en este caso de the big
bang theory
específicamente para ser preciso y el
don es físico teórico y el ingeniero
siempre menospreciado el jaguar
ellos
seguramente todos lo haríamos en la
serie pero maravillosos de sus
disciplinas brillantes pero también lo
que era parte de la trama fundamental de
la serie
lo que podríamos llamar a sociales
no podían conectarse o les costaba mucho
lograr conectarse con los otros y más
aún entender la sociedad en la que
estaban viviendo
la pregunta es si este es el imaginario
que se está construyendo en torno a los
ingenieros hoy en día son estos los
ingenieros que necesitamos en día mañana
son estos personajes los que nos van a
generar más vocación por estudiar
ingeniería
los problemas del siglo 21 son problemas
que nunca antes hemos tenido que
enfrentar
son sistémicos son multis
multidimensionales y son de carácter
global y planetario
que necesitan una comprensión que va
mucho más allá de la disciplina en
particular
por lo tanto que debemos hacer como
debiésemos formar a nuestros ingenieros
es la pregunta que nos planteamos con un
grupo de profesores dentro de la
universidad santa maría y en la cual nos
para lo cual nos unimos en una red
latinoamericana de universidades para
pensar desde latinoamérica lo que
nosotros entendemos por innovación
social y el rol de cada uno de nosotros
en este proceso de innovación
en particular dentro de santamaría demás
creamos el 310 en la oficina de
innovación social que nos permitía dar
mentoría y generar formación en torno a
la innovación social de nuestros
ingenieros pero por lo tanto la pregunta
es cuál es el rol en la innovación de un
ingeniero y en particular de las
herramientas del ingeniero como la
tecnología
es así como lo primero que nos tenemos
que dar cuenta es que la ingeniería y la
tecnología son un medio para lograr
soluciones que vayan encaminadas a
mejorar la calidad de vida de los
individuos y contribuir al bien común
siempre con una perspectiva de
sostenibilidad y no un fin en sí misma
no tecnología por tecnología sino que
algo debe contribuir lo segundo como
buenos ingenieros también nos preguntan
cuáles son las herramientas cuáles son
las capacidades las competencias que
tenemos que construir qué es lo que
tiene que tener un ingeniero para lograr
esa contribución desde la innovación
social primero empatía no podemos tener
estos ingenieros o formar estos
ingenieros sociales empatía desde el
primer momento desde el momento de
entrar en contacto con las sociedades y
las comunidades para poder levantar
cuáles son los problemas pero también
acompañarnos a lo largo de todo el
proceso y compartir con ellos en la
búsqueda de la solución la generación de
los productos o los mínimos productos
viables la implementación y después la
escalabilidad
eso obliga también hay que copiar hoy
día que no podemos hablar de creatividad
nadie va a tener la respuesta a ninguna
disciplina por sí sola sino que tenemos
que acerca de crear en conjunto
contribuyendo en ese pensamiento
sistémico desde el rol de cada uno de
nosotros eso para los ingenieros el psuv
el complejo porque nos obliga a bajarnos
de un pedestal y ser más humilde ser más
humildes entendiendo que nosotros
contribuimos con una parte de la
solución específicamente materializar la
solución que entre todos estamos
pensando materia materializarla a través
precisamente de la tecnología
pero la solución tiene que venir de
todos especialmente de las comunidades
involucradas
hay que ser multidisciplinario en el
amplio sentido de la palabra qué
significa eso no solo entre puros
ingenieros ni de una especialidad ni de
varias especialidades sino que con
distintas profesiones distintos oficios
y por supuesto insisto con las
comunidades y grupos de involucrados
el trabajo en si los independientes solo
en el dentro de un taller dentro de un
laboratorio al estilo de jabón y chandon
no sirven
tenemos que trabajar ya no un y
disciplinar mente sino de que de manera
multidisciplinar
también siempre con un foco en la
sostenibilidad qué significa eso no solo
sostenibilidad ambiental y
sostenibilidad social sino que también
sostenibilidad económica
qué quiere decir eso focalizado en los
costos en cómo controlamos los costos de
esa solución para que sea implementable
en cada una de las situaciones que
nosotros hayamos diagnosticado pero
también incluso dotándola de un modelo
de negocio
un modelo negocio para que para
precisamente darle esos ingresos que le
permitirán ser sostenibles en el largo
plazo y no depender de el
asistencialismo o la filantropía de
ciertos grupos en particular
y por último escalable tenemos que
focalizarnos en problemas locales de
nuestras propias comunidades comunidades
teníamos que partir por nuestro
vecindario pero esos problemas tienen
que ser a su vez escalables en términos
de las soluciones la solución local
tiene que ser posible de llevar a nivel
planetario
por ejemplo lo hicieron
los secos de vis
ingenieros también de la santamaría que
se involucraron con las comunidades los
campamentos muy importante acá en la
región cierto donde están la mayor
cantidad de campamentos de nuestro país
se involucraron con estas comunidades
y se dieron cuenta de que al no disponer
de acceso a agua potable al no disponer
de acceso a alcantarillado tenían un
gran problema de salubridad e higiene
pero también al conversar con ellos al
tomar desayuno al compartir con ellos se
encuentra hay un problema de dignidad
importante
y eso nos lleva a buscar en conjunto con
ellos una solución de
lo que conocemos como baños secos baños
que con prácticamente cero uso de agua
también un impacto ambiental fuerte eso
lograban generar soluciones a los
residuos que se generaban dentro de los
hogares
nada muy maravilloso nada muy
espectacular pero compenetrado con lo
que estas poblaciones necesitan
y por lo tanto devolviéndoles una
dignidad fundamental dentro de sus
distintos hogares
por lo tanto la ingeniería tiene que ser
capaz de vincularse con lo que
entendemos como un proceso de innovación
social ese proceso tiene que partir
desde la detección de los problemas el
levantamiento de las oportunidades y
finaliza cuando somos capaces de generar
cambios en las conductas cambios a nivel
social que permiten mejorar la calidad
de vida de todos nosotros
y no necesariamente son siempre
concentrarnos en ciertos grupos
específicos sino que muchas veces la
consecuencia es de nivel planetario
por ejemplo el caso personal es lo mismo
que buscamos dentro de una innovación
social que entendemos nosotros al creado
al detectar que existe un problema en el
mundo del emprendimiento y la innovación
especialmente cuando hablamos de la
democratización y es lo que precisamente
buscamos a través de la quinta emprende
buscamos democratizar el acceso al
conocimiento la formación e información
en torno al emprendimiento innovación
tratando a su vez también de generar
valor social o poner en valor social a
los emprendedores e innovadores porque
entendemos que ahí está la generación de
riqueza y el desarrollo integral de las
comunidades de esa forma
ponemos en valor social y también
digamos dignidad a emprendedores que
están
contribuyendo al crecimiento sus hogares
o el desarrollo de sus hogares pero
también de sus vecindarios y comunidades
por tanto hoy día no podemos entender el
desarrollo de las sociedades modernas
sostenibles sin que éstas descansen en
lo que llamamos las disciplinas stem
ciencia tecnología ingeniería y
matemática de sus siglas en inglés a
través de estas nosotros somos capaces
de contribuir un desarrollo social y
estoy seguro convencido de que si somos
capaces de enseñar a nuestros niños y
niñas que a través de
las disciplinas de stem nosotros no sólo
generamos tecnologías sino que esa
tecnología busca un impacto o contribuir
en un impacto en la calidad de vida de
las personas mejorando su situación
contribuyendo al bien común desde un
punto de vista sostenible estoy seguro
que vamos a lograr más vocaciones de
ingenieros rompiendo con el paradigma
que separa lo humanista de lo científico
y vamos a poder contar con esos
ingenieros estudiantes de ingeniería e
ingenieros posteriormente que
probablemente van a ser los superhéroes
que hoy en día nosotros necesitamos más
que nunca muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]